one of the problems with training your
network especially very deep neural
networks is that are vanishing and
exploding gradients what that means is
that when you're training a very deep
network you're derivatives or your
slopes can sometimes get you to very
very big or very very small maybe even
exponentially small and this makes
training difficult in this video you see
what this problem of exploding or that
vanishing gradients really means as well
as how you can use careful choices of
the random way the initialization to
significantly reduce this problem less
your training very deep neural network
like this the same space on this slide
I've drawn it as if you have only two
hidden units per layer but it could be
more as well but this neural network
will have parameters W 1 W 2 W 3 and so
on up to WL for the sake of simplicity
let's say we're using an activation
function G of Z equals Z so a linear
activation function and let's ignore be
the set B of l equals 0 so in that case
you can show that the output Y will be W
L times W 0 minus 1 times WL minus 2 dot
dot down to w3 W 2 W 1 times X that
means if you want to just check my math
W 1 times X is going to be Z 1 right
because B where is equal to 0 so Z 1 is
equal to I guess W 1 times X and then
plug V which is 0 but then a 1 is equal
to G of Z 1 but because you use a linear
activation function this is just equal
to Z 1 so this first term W 1 X is equal
to a 1 and then by still everything you
can figure out that W 2 times W 1 times
X is equal to a 2 because that's going
to be G of Z 2 is going to be G of W 2
times a 1
which implies that in here so this thing
is going to be equal to a two and then
yo this thing is going to be a three and
so on until the products all these
matrices gives you the Y hat not Y now
let's say that each of your weight
matrices WL is equal to let's say is
just a little bit larger than one time's
the identity so it's one point five one
point five zero zero right technically
the last one has different dimensions so
maybe this is just the rest of these
void matrices then Y hat will be you
know ignoring those last ones different
dimension will be this one point five
zero zero one point five matrix to the
power of L minus one times X because if
we assume that each one of these
matrices you know is equal to this thing
is really one point five times the
identity matrix then you end up with
this calculation and so Y hat will be
essentially one point five to the power
of L mm mm minus one times X and if L is
large for very deep neural network Y has
will be very large in fact this grows
exponentially it grows like one point
five to the number of layers and so if
you have a very deep neural network the
value of y will explode now conversely
if we replace this with zero point five
so something less than one then this
becomes zero point five to the power of
L where this matrix
um becomes zero point five to the o
minus one times X we can ignoring WL but
so each of your matrices are less than
one then if let's say X 1 X 2 where 1 1
then the activations would be 1/2 1/2
1/4 1/4 1/8 1/8 and so on until this
becomes a right 1 over 2 to the L so the
activation values will decrease
exponentially as a function of the deaf
as a function
the number of layers elves in network so
they be very deep network these
activations end up decreasing
exponentially so the intuition I hope
you can take away from this is that if
the weights W if they're all you know
just a little bit bigger than one I'll
just work with bigger then the identity
matrix then with a very deep network the
activations can explode and if W is you
know just a little bit that's the
identity right so this was maybe is 0.9
0.9 right then if a very deep network
the activations will decrease
exponentially and even though I went
through this argument in terms of
activations increasing or decreasing
exponentially as a function of level the
similar argument can be used to show
that the derivatives or the gradients
you compete with we understand will also
increase exponentially or decrease
exponentially as a function of the
number of layers where some of the
modern neural networks you actually have
l equals hundred and fifty Microsoft
basically got great results of
encountering 52 layer in your network
but whether such a deep neural network
if your activations your gradient
increase or decrease exponentially as a
function of L then these values could
get really big or really small and this
makes training difficult especially if
your gradients are exponentially small
in elm then you know gradient descents
will take tiny little steps they'll take
a long time for gradient descent to
learn anything
to summarize you've seen how deep
networks suffer from the problems of
vanishing or exploding gradients in fact
for a long time this problem was a huge
barrier to training deep neural networks
it turns out there's a partial solution
that doesn't completely solve this
problem but that helps a lot which is
careful choice of how you initialize the
weights to see that let's go on to the
next video